[Musica]
non è vero che a me preoccupa la
comunicazione anzi lo osservo mi piace
cosa sto pensando in questo momento che
le mie due dimensioni spazio e tempo
hanno dei limiti la dimensione temporale
è limitata dal countdown che mi sta
segnando il tempo che ho a disposizione
la disposizione invece di questo cerco i
miei piedi e il limite della mia
dimensione spaziale non posso
travalicare il limite di questo cerchio
rosso perché che uscirei dal fuoco delle
telecamere e quindi perderei
un'occasione unica di lasciare un
momento epico della mia esistenza che
sicuramente mi sopravviverà quindi in
questi quindici minuti
io sto lasciando qualcosa all'umanità
sto realizzando la mia etica individuale
in un luogo privilegiato senza alto
senza dubbio per una storia personale
per una professione per una serie di
botta di fortuna di infamità ho iniziato
a fare il giornalista con una finta
raccomandazione nello zio arcivescovo
che non ho mai avuto ma era l'unica
maniera che si aveva per poter cercare
di ambire a varcare i confini
dell'azienda pubblica dove c'era quel
cavallo movente
detto questo vorrei sfatare innanzitutto
quella che è un luogo comune che viviamo
nell'epoca della comunicazione
no non è affatto vero non è la cifra
fondamentale dell'epoca in cui viviamo
quello che noi comunichiamo non stiamo
comunicando in realtà ci stiamo
semplicemente addestrando a quella che è
una fase inconsapevole della nostra
evoluzione
cerco di essere più chiaro noi più o
meno i miei dati sono del tutto
imprecisi ma faccio il giornalista
perché amo l'imprecisione sono fare lo
scienziato abbiamo più o meno cominciato
a camminare eretti 20 milioni di anni fa
poi abbiamo impiegato altri dai 15 ai 17
milioni di anni per diventare uomini a
tutti gli effetti e qual è stato il
segno della nostra evoluzione perché ne
sono state una specie privilegiata
perché siamo qui noi a parlare dentro un
anfiteatro abbiamo pensieri complessi
per un banalissimo episodio che ci ha
spuntato il pollice opponibile l'inizio
la nostra evoluzione questo pollice che
possa far così possa schioccare le dita
possa abitare un bullone possa
trasformare la mia mano in utenza e
quindi cambiare il mondo attorno a me
una semplice evoluzione il pollice
opponibile ci rende quello che siamo
abbiamo cominciato quindi a trasformare
il mondo avendo il pollice opponibile
cambiavamo il mondo
siamo diventati veramente gli architetti
dell'universo come dicono i massoni ma
lo siamo a tutti gli effetti perché non
ci siamo accontentati di cambiare il
mondo fisico abbiamo cominciato anche a
costruirci un fantastico mondo
metafisico bellissimo e anche in questo
noi siamo stati molto bravi abbiamo
sempre immaginato come abbiamo
cominciato a costruire delle macchine
abbiamo cominciato a costruire delle
macchine cambiassero il mondo la ruota
la leva e poi andando avanti fino
arrivare che ne so la vita senza fine al
cardano tutti gli agli attrezzi aver ci
siamo inventati che via via hanno
costruito la tecnologia abbiamo cambiato
il nostro mondo non abbiamo cambiato
soltanto il nostro mondo ma anche il
nostro mondo delle idee abbiamo
cominciato a costruirci delle
fantastiche architetture per dare
possibilità di visualizzare o di
appoggiare quello che erano i nostri
stati interiori che abbiamo cominciato
acquisire una sensibilità e quindi siamo
costruiti degli universi delle
cosmogonie abbiamo cominciato a pensare
gli dèi abbia cominciato a costruire
degli idoli degli errori che ci somiglia
seco fossero le nostre metafore degli
idoli che parlavano quindi davano a noi
la possibilità di vedere ha presentato
allucinato quello che noi pensavamo di
essere questo fa sempre parte del nostro
cammino evolutivo noi in questo momento
però stiamo compiendo in maniera forse
inconsapevole in circa una ventina
d'anni un santo evolutivo altrettanto
potente per noi come è stato quello che
in 17 milioni di anni ci ha dato il
pollice opponibile è quello di avere
iniziato a pensare l'idea che noi
potessimo avere delle ipotesi emotive
che in qualche maniera andassero oltre
quello che ogni limite nei nostri sensi
ha un po sorriso quando qualcuno ha
detto come che iniziassimo noi
spegnete cellulare come rivela come
spegnere quello che noi abbiamo a
disposizione oggi per osservare a tempo
reale la nostra evoluzione
noi stiamo cercando la stessa maniera in
cui abbiamo cominciato a cambiare il
mondo a cambiare anche la nostra
sensibilità a cambiare la nostra
percezione degli altri esseri umani
della nostra dimensione spazio temporale
proprio attraverso questo oggetto che
ognuno di voi ha il fatto che il mio
nivo ne abbia uno in tasca significano
ormai è una protesi irrinunciabile e
soltanto per un mero arcaismo ancora noi
mese dopo mese vediamo il nuovo modello
di smartphone ci fermiamo rispetto
quello che è l'hardware quello che è la
l'esterno di questo oggetto realtà è la
sua essenza la nostra evoluzione sarà
completa in questa fase quando noi
avremo incorporata questa possibilità
ulteriore di avere degli spazi più ampi
rispetto a quelli limitati dei nostri
sensi come questo cerchio rosso come
quel countdown che segna che mancano 9
minuti e 18 secondi alla fine
questo significa che dobbiamo vedere
osservare essere consapevoli che il
mondo che stiamo vivendo un mondo che
sta registrando il nostro cambiamento
perché noi stiamo cambiando come noi
siamo cambiati con il pollice opponibile
abbiamo cominciato a cambiare il nostro
mondo noi stiamo cambiando con questa
nostra percezione che comunque abbiamo
una nuova maniera per gestire la
socialità la socialità significa
esperienza
il nostro cervello muta cambia con la
relazione con gli altri
una volta un'amica mia è una scienziata
mi ha detto io ti cambio cambio qualcosa
di te mi tocca una mano
con le unghie 5 strumento le tue sinapsi
sono composte una certa maniera quindi
tutto cambiato il cervello tu hai un
cambiamento fisico soltanto per una
carezza
figuriamo quanto cambiamo e quanto
stiamo cambiando dallo stress che non
eravamo abituati a gestire di avere non
so 20 30 mila contatti in un social
network da avere il database organizzato
di tutte le nostre relazioni non avere
più una gerarchia di relazioni se non un
ordine alfabetico e relazioni che noi
gestiamo per questo fantastico questo
cambierà il mondo
questo muterà il mondo attendere noi
riusciremo a incorporare questa facoltà
e come questi occhiali che realtà sono
una protesi senza occhiali comincio a
vedere sfocato dalla prima fila in poi
quindi ho una protesi per acuire quello
il mio senso della vista non mi
basterebbe la vista per gestire 900
persone ma quando mai s'è posto un uomo
il problema di guardare in faccia 900
persone
non ho possibilità fisiche legate ai
miei fan ai miei sensi di gestire il 50
mila contatti che magari ho nel mio
social network quindi ho bisogno una
protesi questa protesi alla fine mi
comincia a pesare il fatto sia un
oggetto che lo tenere fuori dal mio
corpo lavoro dentro quella che era la
fantastica anticipazione di alcuni
performance di body art negli anni 70
come stelarc che si mangiava dei piccoli
meccanismi dicendo il corpo umano è
pieno di zone vuote
bisogna riprogettare il corpo umano ma
noi stiamo riprogettando il corpo umano
noi stiamo dando corpo a una nuova
dinastia di esseri umani anche cambiando
le fattezze fisiche le nostre dimensioni
corporee la nostra espressione mutava
secondo deluso che facevamo
dell'ambiente camminavamo tanto ci hanno
delle gambe lunghe e affusolate e siamo
molto seduti diventiamo sedentari ci
vede la gastrite artificialmente abbiamo
capito che può essere cambiato ma
figuriamoci
non c'è più il tabù diciamo
dell'incorporamento di oggetti estranei
la tecnologia che entra nel nostro corpo
ma che male c'è mi fa male un ginocchio
ormai da qualche anno metterai una
protesi si metrò una cosa al vanadio qua
chi se ne importa mi rischia di
scoppiare il cuore e metteranno un po di
valvole siamo abituati ma sono abituati
non soltanto dell'avanguardia del nostro
pensiero
tutti sono abituati una persona anziana
sa che sta un problema cardiaco
gli mettono dei bypass delle valvole ne
continua a vivere quindi è già superato
il tabù
non esiste più una differenza fra
organico inorganico anzi l'inorganico
entra tranquillamente a far parte del
nostro corpo della nostra esperienza
sono anche altre mutazioni però
mutazioni che in realtà avvengono
proprio per usi sociali
un'altra importante mutazione che
abbiamo avuto è la perdita del bakool um
il baku lum è lo stop è nico che una
volta è importante perché avevamo
poligami c'erano tante donne che servì a
un attrezzo sempre sempre a disposizione
poi sono orientati monogami abbiamo
cambiato le nostre abitudini e mi pare
che un milione e mezzo di anni fa
abbiamo perso il baku lum lo mantengono
alcuni primati l'uomo non ce l'ha più
quindi un uso sociale ha cambiato il
nostro corpo e perché non dovrebbe
cambiare il nostro corpo e un uso
sociale come quello di avere la nostra
possibilità di relazionarci allargata
questo ha sempre appassionato diciamo i
miei ultimi anni di attenzione per tanti
anni osservato la televisione il mio
compito era appunto come la persona mi
sa che mi ha introdotto di fare il
massmediologo interne sempre è sempre
sembrato odioso
anche perché avevo l'impressione di
osservare una realtà transeunte che non
era possibile codificarla in un sistema
scientifico la comunicazione noi
cambiamo continuamente non puoi dire
cosa sia la comunicazione quando nacque
per le facoltà di scienza la
comunicazione video ma scienza di che
questi studiavano televisione i soloni
spiegavano cos'è la televisione teso a
oggi non esiste più
quando lo osservavo io una decina d'anni
fa già dicevo sia un medium
ma perché è un medium è un medium
nell'accezione primaria di questo
termine è un evocatore di realtà
fantasmatiche peso non è importante ci
fa vedere nulla non ci ha fatto evolvere
non è l'oggetto che ha cambierà la
nostra vita
lasciatelo dire quello le vestali che
ogni giorno si strappano i capelli di
cronaca come cambia il mondo
la cattiva televisione della buona
televisione non esiste roba passata è un
medium mai servito per un certo periodo
a farci vedere una realtà di oltre tomba
in cui tutti ambivamo ad entrare era
l'addestratore a la concezione alla
percezione della protesi emotiva
la televisione altro non ha fatto poi
alla fine che osservare l'umanità e non
inventarsi più nulla
la televisione non è più assimilabile a
una realtà come la poesia la narrativa
n'opera telegiornale giorni generalista
parlo la tradizione dei telefilm è
un'altra cosa è una trasposizione del
teatro al teatro a casa la tele giorno
ha fatto altro che osservare la realtà e
cominciare a dimostrare che le persone
che la guardano diventarlo all'interno
del suo spettacolo benissimo tutto
questo l'ho fatto una parte importante
della mia vita quindi osservavo la
comunicazione osservavo i mezzi di
comunicazione dice ma abbiamo queste
protesi emotive incorporate dentro di
noi che bello comunicheremo tanto voglio
studiare e capire immaginare voleva
essere avanti rispetto agli altri capire
sarebbe successo il giorno dopo poi può
improvvisamente nella mia vita accaduto
che mi è nato un figlio autistico
perlomeno ho avuto la percezione che
aveva un figlio autistico un essere
umano ha un problema di comunicazione
la totale incomunicabilità o la radicale
incomunicabilità cadio farà quel punto
li avevo due strade una la strada è
quella che la maggior parte delle
famiglie che hanno ragazzo autistico
fanno in italia sono tante perché
statisticamente ormai nasce un autistico
ogni 100 bambini quindi qualcosa sta
cambiando comunque cominciato osservare
il mondo visto una persona che non
comunica avevo capito qualcosa di
fondamentale in realtà noi ci stiamo
evolvendo e le persone che non comunica
non sono altro che l'anticipazione della
nostra fase futura dell'evoluzione e
stranamente su queste persone si è
creata una sorta di guerra di religione
oggi l'autismo da nero diversità è al
centro di una sorta di nuovo movimento
di rivolta
cosa fate ai nostri bambini li vaccinate
li fate diventare tutti autistici dio
mio che succederà non comunicheranno più
ci togliete questa facoltà fantastica
che tutti noi possiamo esprimere
un'opinione
abbiamo uno smartphone e nel social
network anche se siamo radicalmente
degli analfabeti funzionali possiamo
dire quello che vogliamo quindi la paura
è che quella che viene considerato la
nuova frontiera del potere ottuso e
assoluto che la scienza con la modesta
cosa che ci ha fatto evolversi fa sì che
voi stiate qua in buona salute
che ci sono delle luci che io posso
parlare che lascerò questa fetta della
mia vita in un luogo dove potrà
continuare a parlare con bianchi non ci
sarò più
e diventato il grande spauracchio è
l'oggetto lo storia che sono propri
bambini ci fate morire i nostri bambini
ma guardate che c'è sempre stata una
paura verso quelli che mangiavano i
bambini le prime e pregiudizio verso gli
ebrei che loro ammazzasse i bambini per
berne il sangue fare dei loro rituali ho
cominciato a studiare la non
comunicazione è cominciato a spiegare a
queste persone che non è che ci sono
delle cause esterne dei cattivi che
avvelenano i vostri bambini avvelenano
voi con i vaccini con un'infinità di
altre cose
no i nostri figli sono così perché noi
siamo così ci abbiamo già noi dentro il
nostro patrimonio genetico per fare
questo dimostra questo cosa ho fatto ho
passato due mesi la mia vita a farvi
diagnosticare la percentuale che ho di
autismo e o una forte percentuale di
autismo che riesca a gestire sono
autistico fortemente autistico quindi in
me già vedo la possibilita di questa
nuova evoluzione quale sarà la nuova
società la società degli autistici non
saranno persone che comunicheranno
avranno una comunicazione diversa più
selettiva abbandoneranno alcuni cascami
che in questo momento limite alla nostra
esistenza all'emotività la passionalità
la famiglia tutte queste cose
certo c'è un lato in questo abbastanza
negativo proprio riguardo appunto alla
delimitazione del proprio tempo alla
sopravvivenza
la mia vera angoscia e che avrà un
figlio che mi sopravviverà e questo
sembra paradossale ma non ci dormo la
notte
e assolutamente contro natura avere
paura di un figlio di sopravvivere
perché cercavo un figlio con un cervello
di verso una società che da come valore
soltanto il cervello omologato e quindi
quello che riuscirò a fare in questo
lasso di tempo da quando uscirò da
questo cerchio che delimitano spazio e
quando arriverà 0 il timer che thing del
mio tempo e cercare il più possibile di
lanciare l'orgoglio per i cervelli
diversi il mio sarà un coming out
io ho un cervello diverso sono matto e
allora cos'è la nuova società sarà fatta
di matti come ben sa una scelta diversa
molto più leggera meno legata alle
tradizioni alle convenzioni alle paure
alle superstizioni sarà più efficiente
[Applauso]
[Musica]